all right
you have a huge night tonight you are
hosting
i get to also present with you
what is going through your head
i'm super excited and stoked to be here
it's such an honor and a blessing
what can fans expect from you as a host
a lot of fun
and a lot of subtitles because i talk
real fast and i run my work together
i love that and and you and i are
presenting together so is there anything
i need to know is there anything i need
to prepare
are we going to dance are we go like
what are we doing
i have no idea what we're going to do
we're just going to run it we're going
to have fun
i'm a professional funner are you okay
so what is your
must-have
piece or thing to do when getting ready
to have fun for an event like this like
what did you do before you hit the
carpet tonight i just got to make sure i
have my fox tail on standby okay that's
it i love that and and it's
from there is up
what is the most comfortable thing
you're wearing tonight and what is the
most uncomfortable thing you're wearing
tonight
everything is comfort for me
fashion and comfort goes hand in hand if
it's uncomfortable
i don't want it
i love that let's talk about country
music and it is changing it is evolving
it is growing what does it feel like for
you as an artist to be a huge part of
that
all right it's a blessing it's an honor
and i don't know what country music is
going but i want to be a part of it have
you always loved country music
definitely since i was a little
tinkerbot i love that who have you
looked up to
some of everybody i mean from george
strait to tim mcgraw to sammy smith
aretha franklin i'm just all across the
genre all across the board wow marvin
gaye sam cook donny hathaway i can keep
going okay johnny cash outcast
i love it well thank you so much for
your time and have a great time up there
i'll be cheering you on thank you so
much okay